imagine it's the year 1900
the horse and buggy still reigns supreme
as the choice mode of transportation
but a relative newcomer the automobile
is about to become
all the rage and so roads begin to pave
and things like gas stations and traffic
lights appear
and voila everything looks different
and probably smells a lot better too the
transition from horse to horsepower
ushered in a complete infrastructural
change that had ripples
through every sector imaginable and made
our modern world possible
a century later are we on the cusp of
another transformation of that magnitude
[Music]
today the world pretty much agrees on
the basic idea that
we need to get off fossil fuels and move
toward more sustainable solutions to our
modern needs
the transportation industry accounts for
something like 14 of global greenhouse
gas emissions
and that's one of the largest
contributors of pollution in the world
but going electric is not a simple
panacea for the world's climate problem
we need to understand that electric
vehicle is very good but the battery is
not so green
the more we consume electric vehicles
the more we consume electricity and
electricity is powered by
polluted materials like natural gas or
coal
just like going from 19th to 20th
century mobility
the very infrastructure we built our
society on may need to change
and a lot of unresolved issues remain
before this shift goes into full gear
for example there aren't enough
lithium-ion and cobalt resources in the
world today
and the whole industry is centered on
making sure that there's no anxiety
associated with
with the range batteries don't grow
on trees and for every mile you want to
go they become heavier which then drains
them faster
forcing us to stop and charge up again
and again
and again which of course takes up
energy
and so we're left with the ultimate
riddle how can we move with the ease and
freedom that internal combustion offers
while successfully reducing our overall
carbon footprint
israeli ev startup electron is helping
crack the code
we don't need to remove the battery at
all but we need to reduce
the size of the battery and this will
create a green solution
to all of us we took a step back and we
looked
at the shift to electric vehicles in a
more holistic way
and we said okay what makes the most
sense how can we create
a charging solution where the vehicle
battery can be
as small as it can possibly be when you
think about
battery capacity and battery density
not every vehicle requires a huge
battery
not every vehicle needs to travel
hundreds of miles
so ultimately the vision is to empower
the transition to electric vehicles
in the most sustainable and efficient
way possible whilst ultimately lowering
the cost
of ownership of the vehicles for the
owner and the existing solutions based
on plug-in charging
will not do the shift alone so
we believe that wireless charging is the
technology that can
help to accelerate the adoption of
electric vehicles
yes you heard that right car charging
wirelessly wireless charging
is a way to transmit energy from wine
coil to the other coil without
having hard connection between the two
while we are driving
we can charge it while we are waiting
for passengers inside the city
we can charge it while we are loading
goods at the loading dock so it means
that we can charge the vehicle
almost any time anywhere we don't need
to carry
a huge battery with us we can reduce the
size of the battery
and we can transmit the energy almost
all day long
we have the copper coils that are
installed under the road under the
roadway or wherever it is that we're
deploying
that transfer energy over the air to a
receiver that's
installed directly under the vehicle's
chassis it works on the exact same
principle as an electronic toothbrush
or we're seeing a lot of new generation
wireless charging for
iphones there's no actual connection
required between the two the energy
is via the air wireless charging is
actually nothing new
its use has been around almost as long
as the discovery of electricity itself
the principle is based on nicola tesla
discovery more than 100 years ago
[Music]
nikola tesla was so ahead of his time
that his vision for wireless energy
transformation was
buried by his competitor thomas edison
in favor of a less egalitarian
and more capitalistic system of energy
transmission
today he's practically worshipped by the
tech elite and the tesla coil remains
the inspiration for wireless internet
connections
as well as charging solutions like
electrons
this charging can occur even when the
car is moving and comes with a holistic
power management system to maximize the
process
electrons technology is made up of four
major components
there's the copper coils directly under
the road there's the receiver
unit which accepts the energy from the
copper coils
under the road then that relationship is
managed by a management unit
at the side of the road which receives
energy directly from the grid and then
safely transfers it to the copper coils
under the road
these three components are managed by
cloud software
which enables us to remotely monitor the
entire relationship
make sure enough energy is being
transferred and ultimately
charge and bill for the energy the
benefits of wireless charging are huge
when we look at the transition to
electric mobility
there are a lot of costs incurred on the
vehicle side and on the infrastructure
side
installing the technology means a
vehicle's battery capacity
can be massively reduced which can be up
to 50 percent of the cost of the vehicle
itself
the vehicle never needs to stop to
charge again you can charge
with different amount of energy
different vehicles on the same platform
which is very unique to wireless
charging
just as in the transition from horses to
automobiles
public infrastructure plays a critical
role in enabling mass adoption
but making major changes to large
complex systems
while they're in use isn't easy there is
no standard for
wireless charging dynamically ultimately
in order to be able to enter the market
and offer our technology at commercial
scale
we need standardization of the
technology so
of course we're looking in this case an
involvement with the local government
municipality
regional transport authority whatever it
may be that
funds the infrastructure deployment on
the one side and then the user
the vehicle itself or the owner of the
vehicle will be charged
for the amount of energy that's
transferred to them in the same way that
you pay for roaming services or a
vehicle today is charged
when you deal with disruptive technology
you need to educate the market you need
to deal with standardization
regulation you need to teach lots of
students
and bring them to the company you need
to gain new knowledge
you need to learn from other mistakes
we need the electric companies and the
grid companies
to work together to figure out how best
to
deploy this technology in terms of the
grid requirements
at scale and that's what all of the
pilots that we're working on are aimed
at
figuring out all the pieces of the
puzzle
implementing this technology sounds like
quite an ordeal but then again if
there's anything that is
constantly being worked on already it's
roads
we're talking about scraping off just a
small amount of the center of the road
to deploy the technology
and doing it as quickly as possible so
today we can lay a kilometer in just one
night
so really limiting impacts uh to the
road
you know if we're doing it on one side
of the road then the public can still
use the other side of the road
the different direction and making sure
that as much of the preparatory work
is done ahead of time as possible
limiting impacts to road users
in few hours we can take an existing
electric vehicle
and we can install our unique receiver
pad
connected directly to the battery and
then you can drive
so it's very easy to convert or to deal
with any type
any kind of electric vehicles what's
really interesting about this technology
is
how it fits into each different type or
use case
so of course there are the vehicles that
require long long range
you know long-haul trucking companies
for example traveling between states or
between countries want an extended
mileage when we think about last mile or
delivery vans well they're limited today
by
the vehicle's battery capacity and how
often they need to charge
but essentially with this technology
they could run double shifts
if we look at city taxis just as an
example from the mobility as a service
world they're also limited by the amount
of charge required
ultimately if we installed charging
technology along the areas where they
were resting they'd be able to operate
for longer hours
buses too which operate on fixed routes
so it makes perfect sense for them to be
able to charge while driving
and save downtime there is a huge need
for electric buses so we decided to
start with this section
we have one kilometer of electrified
road we will drive the bus
and you will see that it transmits
energy during driving
every hour we get 75 kilowatts charging
the bus that means that in two hours we
get 150 kilowatts
this is half of the amount of energy
that the bus needs to drive all day long
that means that we can reduce the size
of the battery by half
and lead to great savings and cost of
the bus battery and the bus itself
once we're gonna drive the bus we're
gonna see that the bus driver doesn't
need to do anything this is the beauty
of it
for him it's a normal boss he doesn't
need to change anything in his driving
electron is not relying on this test
site alone as a proof of concept
they have several projects around the
globe in various stages we have
a project in gotland sweden where we
show the charging of a large truck a 40
ton truck
and a large electric bus showing the
capacity for battery reduction as the
vehicles are charged directly from the
road
in tel aviv we're showing that
ultimately a bus can operate
an extended or 24 7 service with higher
frequency trips
because it doesn't need to stop for
dedicated charging time
in italy we're going to be deploying an
interesting project
with a toll road operator which is a
classic use case for us right if you as
a user are already paying
to use a toll road why not also get
energy transfer to your vehicle then
and charge your car part of electreon's
vision
is in alignment with the trend of
increasing public spaces
in urban environments we're talking
about infrastructure that's essentially
invisible it's under the road
so no changes to the road surface no
noise
no additional use of space so if we look
at the urban environment for example
it makes more sense to have dedicated
space for pedestrians
for cyclists to increase the amount of
space for them
and to not have the focus on the visible
charging infrastructure
in keeping with nikola tesla's
egalitarian ideals
electreon plans on sharing their
solutions with the world at large
so our approach is a bit different we
are going to
offer the ips for free for
a car manufacturer in order to increase
the adoption of wireless charging
this sort of open source ip sharing is
typical of the silicon valley set
elon musk did the same in the hopes of
moving to a new generation of
sustainable development
as the rising tide does raise all ships
electron even as it proves its concept
and takes on more partners
remains in its infancy there's still
some questions about the economics
behind
their product and if it's able to be
deployed around the world but they are
picking up steam
with several projects in in europe and
uh and plans would expand
in the u.s and capture on president
biden's
initiative to try to ramp up ev
infrastructure in the country
that's a big if since there's no
guarantee that electron will receive the
benefits of biden's infrastructure plan
not to mention that they're not the only
game in town siemens
e-highway elways and elon road all claim
to have commercial-ready
electric road systems but the electron
team and their ambitions remain
undeterred by competition
and held strong by an unwavering faith
in their core mission
the real question is is what are we
doing to limit the environmental impacts
of electric mobility how we're making it
truly sustainable
and that's how i was really able to get
behind the vision that the founders have
here
and what they're trying to do and as for
the daunting task of
altering the world's roads for wireless
charging electron is taking it
one kilometer at a time when you start
something that
the beginning you need to put lots of
effort to start moving this change
but once you are in a motion then it
will be much easier
to move fast and fast and accelerate
[Music]
you